I want to start today talking about
Florida and yeah in a certain sense this
is a story about Ron DeSantis but it is
really a story about Ron DeSantis as
Governor not Ron DeSantis as the maybe
future failed Republican presidential
primary candidate Ron DeSantis who still
as of this moment has not announced that
he is running against Donald Trump in
that Republican primary I want to show
you the texture of the right wing
hellscape that DeSantis is rapidly
transforming Florida into now full
disclosure I know people will email me
but David you say these things about
Florida and then you go to Florida okay
I also said things that are terrible
about Donald Trump and I lived in the
United States when Trump was President
so uh yes there are parts of Florida
that I think are great even though they
have infrastructure problems as a result
of of Ron DeSantis and right-wing State
policy those liberal parts of Florida
with the good restaurants as Alex Jones
would say
uh yeah I frequently go there and I
don't understand how that devalues in
any way the criticism of the policy that
the scientist has put in place so CNN
recently had this uh list that they put
up let's take a look at it in recent
times Ron DeSantis has signed a six-week
abortion ban ended concealed weapons
permits the requirement for such permits
ban gender affirming care for Trans
youth restricted drag shows expanded the
don't say gay law blocked and uh an
advanced placement African-American
studies curriculum class and prohibited
vaccine mandates first of I I am going
to make two arguments to you here first
argument all of these bills and laws are
terrible ideas and number two many of
them also directly contradict the stated
values of low government intervention
little government and involvement
freedom and liberty that they claim to
espouse so let's go through some of
these six-week abortion ban DeSantis
signed that in a closed door ceremony I
believe it was last month the bill
prohibits Physicians from performing
abortions after six weeks into a
pregnancy in most cases as I've
explained before
many women
don't even know they're pregnant until
the six week Mark because when you've
missed your period
if you are pregnant you're basically
five weeks pregnant four five depending
on who you ask or you know the the
particulars of that so
it is completely unrealistic absolutely
unreasonable and it is close to a full
abortion ban It also says that if you
want an exception because you've been
raped you have to provide evidence of
the rape
okay uh if it's the result of incest or
human trafficking you need to provide
evidence and that only gets you an
exception up to 15 weeks this is if Roe
v Wade were still in place it would
blatantly violate Roe v Wade it's
another attempt to control women's
bodies and limit choices and it is
insane government overreach we have the
bill that lets you concealed carry
without a permit okay DeSantis signed
this also last month this allows gun
owners to carry firearms in public
without any additional permitting or
training required and it also ends the
state requirement that when you leave
your home with a concealed weapon you
must have special training not even
special just training I think is what we
would call it it's a gift to the gun
lobby it's a gift to the NRA it's a gift
to the more guns and more places and it
will make Florida less safe it will make
Florida more prone to gun violence and
accidents we then have this package of
five bills that were passed
uh and signed into law by Ron DeSantis
and here we are talking about
um a lot of bills that relate directly
to the rights of the LGBT community and
here we're talking about a ban on gender
affirming care for Trans youth this will
prevent doctors from providing hormone
therapy or surgery to minors who
identify as trans You could argue that
it is a form of denial of medical care
that you're just you're taking away
medical freedom because what we're
talking about here is saying hey here's
people who may need certain Services as
determined by medical professionals
instead you have some Republican
lawmakers saying you're not going to be
allowed to do it restrictions on drag
shows this is a law that will prohibit
any establishment that serves alcohol
from hosting performances by drag queens
or drag Kings you can argue that this is
discrimination against a form of
artistic expression you can argue this
violates Free Speech because at the end
of the day we're not talking about
grooming or pedophilia or sexual assault
or any of the things that they love to
say are inextricable uh from drag shows
it's a form of expression and it's a
government Banning that we will see what
happens there's the expansion of don't
say gay don't say gay prohibits teachers
from discussing sexual orientation or
gender identity except does it are you
allowed to say as a female teacher oh my
male husband well that is a discussion
of gender identity but that's not banned
because we know what the real point of
it is it's to censor a and silence LGBT
voices experiences and the reality that
uh all sorts of different types of
people exist in our society and culture
there's the bill
um in addition to this which we talked
about before that blocks the advanced
placement African-American studies class
from being offered in public schools
remember they framed it as they are
forcing this indoctrination onto our
children it's an optional class in my
experience uh it's not as though
advanced placement classes
are exactly super popular I mean that
you know they often feel but what I mean
is it's not like the entire school is
even looking to take these classes it's
a whitewashing of History it denies many
of the struggles of black Americans and
we've talked about it before and then
lastly a bill that bans any vaccine
mandates by any entity in Florida that
includes businesses Schools and
Government agencies now whatever your
feelings are about a coveted vaccine
requirement and I'm there with you if
indeed the covet vaccine doesn't prevent
transmission there is a case to say it
shouldn't be required the counter would
be if it reduces the chance of
hospitalization and death
for military Readiness it certainly
seems like it could make a difference
but my point is step back from the covet
vaccine
think about how Reckless and
irresponsible it is to say you can't
have any vaccine requirements that you
can't have any vaccine mandates when we
have so many vaccines that do prevent
transmission and are quite literally
Public Health uh godsends there's
probably some better word I could use
that's less religiously uh uh oriented
these are bills that are harmful to
Floridians but they're also harmful to
democracy and many of them run directly
counter to the stated values that these
Republicans claim to espouse which is
they say freedom Liberty do whatever you
want government only involved when
absolutely necessary freedom of speech
freedom of expression except well no
drag shows and no doctors and patients
deciding what's best for them and all
these other things the takeaway is their
principles evaporate as soon as they
conflict with the political reality that
they are trying to fight radical and
repugnant Republican congresswoman
Marjorie Taylor green
now has come up with the wild claim
that antifa killed a police officer this
is not true this took place during a
recent hearing lgbtq Nation says
Marjorie Taylor green told Congress
antifa killed a cop she was dead wrong
police shot Manuel Teran 57 times green
said their proof that leftists kill cops
let's go to the hearing where Marjorie
Taylor green is now wearing glasses
apparently an attempt to look more
intelligent I don't know
I want to talk about human lives well is
sir
Target for anti
and he murdered someone there they
actually murdered a place oh you don't
know that's right because you don't
study left-wing extremism from your
nonpartisan uh so-called non-profit but
let me tell you about it there was a a
26 year old activist manual uh Tehran
shot and killed Georgia State Patrol
Trooper there that was this year you're
right not last year it was this year so
left-wing extremism is definitely on the
rise and murder is a big part of it okay
that is false and misleading the
individual she's referring to and it's
not manual like your VCR manual it's
Manuel Manuel was not a member of antifa
he was an environmental activist who
opposed the con construction of a police
training facility in Atlanta
he was killed by police officers who
shot 57 times during a raid on the
protest Camp no police officer was
killed in the incident just it's not
what it's not even a question of who did
The Killing no police officer was killed
in the incident there was a state
trooper injured by a gunshot it might
have come from a fellow officer and it
might have come from the officer's own
firearm
okay that's a very different story to
what Marjorie Taylor green told there so
is she a liar of course
is she dishonest yeah is she ignorant
absolutely does she have no business in
a position of legislative power in the
United States a hundred and ten percent
but it's also important to understand
the dangerous nature of how they Inspire
violence this is a form of stochastic
terrorism where if you lie enough
about the supposed acts of violence that
are being committed by your political
opponents when they are not committing
such acts of violence
you in a way
Inspire
legitimize or approve of signal approval
for your side continuing to to commit
the act of violence that they are
actually committing remember the
overwhelming political violence in the
United States is right wing and then I
mean listen we've talked about this
before the the numbers no matter how you
slice and dice them are very clear
and so this is not only all based on
lies I would argue it is a form of
stochastic terrorism by Marjorie Taylor
green we will see whether these sorts of
folks get another
a swing at the ball I don't know what
you want to call it but uh in 2024
we may see these sorts of folks made a
more permanent part of American politics
or it may be the end of Maga My Hope Is
that 2024 is the end of Maga I don't
know that I will be correct a Monday
Memorial Day we will have our one day
membership special I would really love
for you to become a member on Memorial
Day you know we've been doing the show
for a long time and as I've said before
we estimate that somewhere between 0.7
and 0.9 percent of our audience supports
us financially that's fine we do the
show quite literally for the 99.3
percent that don't contribute and we're
glad to do it
it also is true if we were able to get a
full one percent of our audience
supporting our work or even one and a
half percent it's a game changer the
things we would be able to do so I would
love for you to join the ranks of
membership yes you do get the daily
bonus show and you become a member oh
the bonus show
everybody
as you can see Alex Jones hates the
bonus show but on Monday Memorial day
we'll be blowing out memberships at
prices I can't even mention out loud
because it would just make my face red
so get on my newsletter at
davidpackman.com and then Monday
Memorial day you'll get an email it'll
tell you what to do and we will do the
thing
don't forget that the best way to
support the David packman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com joinpakman.com
the David pakman show continues to be an
audience supported program which you can
support if you want listen if you don't
want to support the show still available
for free to everybody we produce it for
everybody but if you were able to be
part of the you know roughly 0.8 0.9
percent of the audience that supports us
financially you can sign up at
joinpakman.com and I think that that
would be a beautiful thing to do let's
hear from people in the audience we take
calls via Discord at davidpackman.com
Discord I want to go first to Ben from
Florida things are insane in Florida
they're blocking Holocaust textbooks
they're allegedly investigating a
teacher because she played a Disney
movie for her class that had a gay
character I mean just it's crazy what's
happening there Ben uh what's on your
mind today
yes I can
all right hey man thanks uh so I wasn't
gonna call and talk about that I'm
actually uh uh currently in the Air
Force abandoned for 19 years now and
there's a
a trend that's kind of irritating so
you know the right has always talked
about the woke military and so forth
um
my question is
you know what are your thoughts on the
fact that they're saying we're awoke
military but like for example when I go
to the gym
there's like six screens in there in a
cardio room
three of which are all on Fox News and
so I've done like a little uh
I guess social experiment where I've
changed it to like MSNBC or CNN yep you
come back the next day they're all back
on Fox news but now you said three of
the six are on Fox what are the other
three on
Like Home Shopping Network uh ABC and
ESPN okay
yeah so it's like very biased and so
like I talked to other people in the
military and other veterans and so forth
and there are so many people that are so
far right and it's just mind-boggling to
me as a veteran who's been to Iraq
multiple times yeah I don't understand
how they can continue to support these
ideals like the trumpists and all that
kind of stuff
you ever ask them I mean it sounds like
you have much more contact with you know
I can't say that right now I'm regularly
in touch with any right-wing military
person what what do they say as to why
they're supporting Maga
oh because Biden and the Democrats are
always terrible for the military and
socialists and it's basically the same
regurgitated BS that you hear from like
if you were watching Tucker or right you
know any anything like that so
um I guess I just wanted to kind of get
that out there you know that that the
narrative is the right that the right's
putting out is it's a world military
that is not the case the military
unfortunately is so far supportive of
trump and his ideals and that and all
that kind of stuff it's really kind of
uh
irritating to me and kind of scare him
like dude these are people that I've
gone to war with and they know what we
go through but they do not really
support what our uniform is supposed to
stand for so do you find that your
branch the Air Force is more or less
Maga than the rest of the military
say that it's more matter than you would
really expect
um no offense to other branches I
apologize for the truck going but
um no offense for the other branches but
the Air Force typically is the one that
you have to have the higher uh standards
for as far as asvabs you'd think they'd
be a little bit more uh educated I guess
you could say
um but it's very much to the point where
even if you point out hey look Biden got
us the highest raise that we've had in
the past 20 years right yeah well that's
really something that Trump put into
place I'm like how far off are you guys
yeah that's tough that's tough so are
you this is your career you're in the
middle you're a career military person
do you see yourself shifting to
Something in the private sector at some
point or you want to stick it out
so I
here left till I can retire oh okay
yeah I'm gonna ride it out and you know
I might do over 20 but to be honest with
you man if if Trump somehow finds his
way back it to uh to DC it may be time
to punch out before it gets even worse
so well but but by then you'll be able
to retire it sounds like because it'll
be more than a year before that happens
right but you know sometimes you know I
at once I thought about man maybe I'll
do over 20 22 25 years I do love my job
yeah at the same time it's getting
harder and harder every year maybe to
stick it out so yep no I understand that
listen Ben from Florida fascinating
insights thank you for your service and
I appreciate you calling in
all right Dave thanks for talking to me
all right there has been from Florida
wow I mean downright scary stuff
happening in the military and we we know
it right I mean we've covered extremism
in the military white supremacy in the
military Etc let's go to another Bend
this time we'll go to Ben from France
Ben from France I assume this is you're
coming from the country of France is
that correct
this is true welcome hey David yeah I'm
I'm actually American but I've been
living in France since about 2018. so uh
it's been it's been good here um what
are you over there having Health Care
without paying for it and stuff like
that you think you're better than us
yeah yeah just for a quick anecdote like
I I I have had a small fracture on my
elbow a couple years ago and uh without
health insurance I had just a basic
Social Security I paid like 50 euros for
a couple X-rays and medication and all
that so yeah
are you in Paris or elsewhere
uh I'm gonna be in Paris uh this
upcoming couple weeks uh but I live in
Brittany usually oh but I have never
been but I hear it's delightful
it is yeah this is where actually my my
mom is from so I'm gonna have to get up
there all right I get those buckwheat
grapes you know I need those buckwheat
Crepes yeah not quite the ones you have
in the US right yeah exactly all right
well let me not not take up more of your
time please go ahead that's all right
yeah I know so I've been thinking um you
know been living here for a while and
watching the the US content for a while
and I I notice
it's um really the the culture wars is
taking up more and more of the air it
seems like and uh we don't quite have
the same thing here in Europe we do have
somewhat of it but uh you know I I still
think like the the workers issues and
economic policy don't get quite the
quite the discussion that they should
because my I guess my question for you
is does this concern you at all and like
what economic policy do you think would
you like to focus more on if you had
more of an opportunity to
um for example I've been writing for a
while on the universal basic income
um I think unions are great but uh
unless everyone has a union it's unions
can become also kind of classist in
their own sense yeah no listen I mean
what there is a sickness here in the
United States and I follow a lot of
foreign foreign to the U.S content
creators certainly many in France Italy
and Spain as well as in my birth country
of Argentina and elsewhere and what I
what I hear many of them say either
publicly or sometimes in private
Communications that I have with some of
these folks is that much of the world is
looking at the United States culture war
and saying it seems like very serious
mental illness quite frankly or short of
it like it's just the country has gone
completely insane and the stories around
labor and workers rights and getting to
you know we're at a point where we don't
really we could eliminate poverty we
could certainly eliminate hunger we
could certainly get everybody access to
health care and we're arguing about you
know like I said earlier Florida's
Banning Holocaust textbooks because
they're woke and someone showed a movie
with a gay character so now that's an
investigation it is a form of insanity
and when you step outside of the US even
briefly like I did a couple weeks ago
when I went to London you realize that
number one this isn't going on in the
rest of the world and number two we look
insane here in the United States
right so uh I guess well which which
it's it's true but then at the end of
the day you have to be thinking like
okay uh what what what kind of things
should we focus on if we had if ideally
we we could and you know the the culture
War wasn't sucking up so much air well
certainly we should be focusing on
economics inequality workers rights as I
mentioned we should be coming together
to say hey here's what we're going to do
about climate change and we're going to
find the balance between people getting
to live the lives they want and also not
destroying the planet here's how we're
going to manage emerging technology and
we're going to have logical
conversations about emerging technology
here's a forward-looking uh energy plan
that's going to get us increasingly on
Renewables I mean there's there's no
shortage of things that we could and
should be focusing on but to a degree
you know you can't ignore all of the
cultural stuff the right is doing
because if you do and they simply win on
all of it it hurts our ability ability
to deal with all of those other things I
just mentioned so it's a very tough
situation
it is yes and I I hope you get the
opportunity to do a little bit more I
mean I I don't watch your every single
uh video or email that you have but uh I
I do hope that you are able to you know
um kind of kind of cover a little bit
more that and focus more about that in
the future again uh Universal base can
come in something that I've been
thinking about for a while it's an
interesting solution to me but I
obviously that's a that's a very big
conversation and I think it would be
nice to see different ideas and uh and
uh kind of like taking a little bit more
from ideas that are happening elsewhere
in the world not not so much France
absolutely absolutely Ben are you at
some kind of Carnival or Carousel
there's a strange it's almost like a
ding dong truck in the background
yeah you know actually I was I was kind
of trying to like look at that I I
thought I thought it was coming from
this server because I don't know where
it's coming from I've closed out all my
browsers and everything
um I don't know where this is coming
from but there's not an ice cream truck
outside of your window or anything no we
don't have those here well we just have
uh yeah no no ice cream trucks
unfortunately but uh but I I'm okay with
the lower cost of healthcare that's very
good it seems like a fair trade Ben from
France thank you very much
no problem yeah all right there goes Ben
let's go next to Mo from West Virginia
Mo from West Virginia welcome what's on
your mind today sir
hi David
um I just wanted to ask you um it might
be a two-part question sure uh one is
that I I see you on mostly left-wing
media uh corporate media does this too
where they say that Trump and DeSantis
are too far to the right when it comes
to policies and positions to gain
traction with Independence they're
turning off Independence well as we all
have seen in the past before
the primaries come first so obviously
they're going to go for the right
Wingers to win their primaries because
after the primaries there's a lot of
shift in their policies and positions to
gain back some momentum with
Independence
do you see like uh anyone in the media
actually like paying attention to that
is that a thing that could happen with
the santis or Trump
I think it'll happen to a degree with
both of them if they win the primary but
we'll all realize it's not genuine and
also I think right now the environment
is such that they all know they need to
play to this extreme Maga right that
remember doesn't really even care about
policy they care about culture issues
fighting wokeness owning the libs and
some very vague you know I'll build a
wall or whatever
um I actually think there's more risk
right now to the Republican candidate of
playing to the middle in the general
that they will they will turn off some
of those extreme voters so I think to
some degree whoever wins the Republican
primary will make a slight play to the
middle I think it won't be as much as we
often see because it's really risky and
I think it will be transparently
disingenuous
where's the risk though because once
they win the primary they're that you're
Republican guy so they've got the risks
you have to remember right now Maga is
made up of the traditional Republican
electorate
plus people who only ever started
following politics because of trump many
of those people if they become
disaffected with whoever it is Trump
DeSantis whatever they will stay home
and then it'll really hurt your ability
to win that's the risk that they will
just say this wasn't what I thought I
was getting I'm staying home screw them
they are willing to do that because they
are not traditional historical voters
that vote every election and so those
folks are much more open to simply not
voting at all
I guess that's true but that's mostly I
see that as a bigger risk but DeSantis
than Trump because Trump trump has that
voter base like I feel like even
DeSantis voters if Trump becomes the
winner of the primary they'll still vote
for Trump just because he's the
Republican they're not going to vote
Democrat in any situation
votes you're right they mostly will but
this is a very unusual situation where
at this point Trump pretending to Pander
to the middle a little bit is not going
to really win him any votes because
it'll be so obviously disingenuous and
it has the risk of turning off some of
his supporters I think the most likely
outcome is Trump just doesn't do it and
he doesn't play to the middle at all
Trump doesn't
yes that's my guess that's my prediction
do you see any specific policies that
you think he would be more likely to
flip on or positions he takes right now
that he would be willing to give up I
really don't and remember he barely
takes any policy positions I mean he's
running a social issues anti-woke I won
in 2020 they treated me unfairly Biden's
a Marxist type of campaign it's already
pretty devoid of policy so there's not
that much policy he even could flip on
right there's no nothing like he doesn't
give out specifics but like I mean I
guess he said he would do it he was
going to build tent cities and force
homeless people into right maybe he'll
cancel that plan I don't know
right but like his position on Ukraine
where he was asked in the town hall like
would you stop supporting Ukraine who do
you want to win the war he's he's not
taking a side he kind of just made an
appeal to emotion saying he just wanted
people to stop dying exactly right
do you see him leaning one way or
another more
just I'm really not sure you know it's
it's it's it's it's just a it's a Fool's
errand to try to predict exactly Which
Way Trump will lean on these issues
it'll be whatever he thinks will benefit
him at the time based on what's being
said on Fox News and what people around
him are saying it's it's not even worth
taking a guess I just have no idea
so you'll think he'll stick to whatever
people around him are saying more yeah
even if they're not like he really his
like advisors on helping him win the
election per se that's what he said
historically
okay yeah
all right my friend uh I appreciate Mo
from West Virginia great to hear from
you let's take a very quick break and
then we'll take more calls so hang on if
you're waiting to talk to me
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show let's go
back to the phones they're not really
phones it's Discord at davidpackman.com
Discord and hear from a few people in
the audience let's go to Tony from New
Jersey Tony from New Jersey welcome to
the program what's on your mind today
Tony from Jersey welcome please unmute
yourself
and Tony one last opportunity to unmute
yourself if you'd like to chat
all right Tony from Jersey a no-go let's
try Tai from Iowa Ty from Iowa welcome
to the program
hello David can you hear me yes I can
okay so I just wanted to bring this up
because there's just something I've kind
of noticed so I mean this is kind of a
while ago but
I I always kind of notice whenever
there's a shooting they just say like
well there's nothing we can really do
about it because there's you're never
going to stop a shooting by doing this
or still going to happen right
but
um there was a shooting done by a person
that was trans I mean that happened a
while ago and I've never seen people on
the right talk about shootings as much
as they did but then it just came up yes
and I was like do you realize how many
people have done shootings that were
like neo-nazis and right-wing extremists
and all this other stuff yeah I mean I
don't know it just doesn't really make a
lot of sense to me it kind of feels like
they need to say
this side that I don't like is the one
doing it that's when I can actually care
about this issue and actually
acknowledge that it's an actual issue
but I won't focus on the fact that
I don't know like maybe
people did this because they're
propagated and all this other stuff they
people might listen to what I say and
then I go out and commit violence or
the
there really isn't the gun restrictions
on the United States really aren't
strong enough people keep getting all
these guns United States is the only one
with this problem and I'm like just one
happens and it's just kind of they go
nuts and I was just kind of I don't know
that's what do you make of that yeah and
I I mean to focus in on what you said a
lot of different things many of them
most all of them valid
um one of the particulars that you
mentioned is this idea of well there's
no way to prevent every mass shooting
like if someone's really determined blah
blah blah you know we've heard that
before and it's it's a very silly
argument because aren't we still better
off if we dramatically reduce the number
of mass shootings or we reduce the
number of people killed in each mass
shooting like these are still all worthy
goals and it's sort of like hey you know
seat belt laws aren't going to save
people if the car uh ends up at the
bottom of a lake okay right but in some
scenarios the seat belts will save
people so we should still do it and then
let's figure out what to do about the
drowning maybe we need better guard
rails on Bridges and you know things
like this it's a similar sort of idea
and it's um it's it doesn't even
remotely pass the I seriously want to
fix this test when people start with
you're never going to prevent every mass
shooting or there's no way to stop a
truly determined person well a lot of
people are aren't maybe as determined
and they would be dissuaded by any of
the 10 or 12 different initiatives I've
proposed so it's not a serious argument
when people start with that that's it's
defeatist and it's uh unrealistic in
terms of finding improvements that we
can make and there's many improvements
we can make
yeah I mean it applies to a lot of other
things I just think that was probably
the one that sickened me the most was it
just kind of felt like they were just
using
um the lives of people that were killed
and all this other stuff just to to be
transphobic and it just kind of happens
that was kind of disgusting all of a
sudden they have 10 ideas of how we
would prevent shootings by trans people
and they all involved denying people
gender affirming care and uh not not
using their preferred pronouns it's
crazy it's a crazy situation
yeah that's unfortunate yeah all right
Ty from Iowa thanks for the call
thank you for taking my call David all
right there goes Ty let's go next to
Jessica from Indiana Jessica from
Indiana welcome to the program what's on
your mind today hello hello can you hear
me yes I can
perfect perfect so I do want to go ahead
and say that I am from Indiana I do want
to go ahead and apologize for Mike Pence
apology accepted yeah so I am a brand
new voter I uh just recently with my
first uh local election with it being uh
speculated that Ronnie is going to be
running for the Republican nomination in
like next week uh Trump having even more
accusations of corrupts in the sexual
harassment and so on how do you see the
near future of American politics being
especially for a young person in a very
very red State like Indiana I hate to
say this but I think until the 2024
election is resolved I don't think we
are going to see any serious adult
policy conversations about materially
improving the lives of young people in
red States I do believe that Joe Biden
has done a lot of little things that are
good little things on Health Care little
things on student loans Etc and I think
to the extent that he's is able to act
unilaterally he will but this election
is shaping up to be such a mess that I
just don't think there's going to be the
bandwidth for serious National
conversations about substantive policy
that will move us more in the direction
of where we want to go so my message to
young people in red states where things
aren't going well this is a sad message
and it's not a realistic one for many
people but it's if you want to
immediately improve your circumstances
you may want to consider moving to a
state where things are already better if
you don't think you can wait it out at
least until 2025. I hate that that's
what's going on but I will say one more
thing that's a little less negative
which is that there are still
opportunities
to make other types of improvements if
you get involved locally and that might
mean City Council in Indianapolis or
whatever the case may be I don't want to
say that there's no opportunities to
make progress but from the federal
discussion it's going to be a mess until
the next at least until the next
president is inaugurated yeah I will say
Indianapolis is relatively good I mean
we just had we elected a um Democratic
Socialist to city council here in
Indianapolis so that's pretty cool there
you go
and uh one's one final question uh so
myself and my family do have to drive
out of state uh typically to missing
Michigan uh to enjoy ourselves some
marriage Awana some Mary Jane if you
will uh when do you think that weed is
going to be legalized in all 50 states I
honestly have no idea I I genuinely
don't know could it could it be five
years could it be ten I I'm not sure I I
think that there will be some red state
holdouts for a very long time
um
well fair enough thank you so much all
right Jessica from Indiana thank you
very much for the call why don't we go
next to Dev from Syracuse Deb from
Syracuse New York welcome to the program
hello again David how are you I'm doing
well
I have a question for you today that's
not related to politics well everything
is Loosely but I hope that excites you
um something that's very important to me
is the live event Music Space uh I've
been going to concerts since my early
20s regularly all year every year and
some thing that I've been seeing that's
very concerning is a lot of Acts or
festivals uh
basically not able to continue in the
way that they envisioned their event to
to take place because of the
Stranglehold from Live Nation and
Ticketmaster which are only the same now
uh there's some estimates that Live
Nation Ticketmaster own uh over 70 of
all live event space at this point the
United States yeah uh so
I think there's a big problem when the
artists aren't able to
uh you know make the event the way that
they plan on it I mean music itself is
an art
it should be expressed in from an
artist's perspective in my opinion at
least
um not so corporatized I'm curious if
you yourself attend live music uh with
any frequency and what's your take on
this corporate takeover of something
that I truly love so the corporate
takeover of the ticket sales I have been
speaking about for more than a decade
it's outrageous between the
consolidation as well as the fees it
unmitigated disaster and I've been
crystal clear about that as far as me
attending live music I used to attend
music very regularly when the pandemic
started I stopped attending live music
events and I haven't gone back and I'll
tell you why it's a couple different
things my tolerance for the crowds and
the parking and the security line and
the traffic on the way out the bumper to
bumper in the parking lot and all of
this stuff I've lost my patience for it
Dev I really have maybe I I've just
gotten too old for it and then number
two you know
let's be honest the body odor and the
ten dollar Waters and the entire thing I
just like I did it for decades I've been
to endless shows I love music I'll
listen to Live albums all the time but
it has not piqued my interest to get
back to live music events since uh since
the pandemic
fair enough I mean to each their own I I
still Revel in the body odor and well I
don't like the 10 Waters I love crowds
and the excitement the activity meeting
new people yeah one of my favorite
things about it besides the music itself
well this is the great thing about
America you can go and I don't have to
and everybody's better for it I just
wanted to give a shout out to summer
camp music festival I'll be attending uh
that next week but unfortunately it's
another one that is going to go on an
unknown term Hiatus due to difficulties
with logistical challenges they didn't
spell it out in plain English but I have
my suspicion that it has a lot to do
with this corporatization of live event
where is that event held that's in
Illinois oh okay you know I'll be
driving this is so insane this was one
of my my worst Live Concert Experience
was
um I went to this insane right-wing
nuttery thing called Country Thunder now
I know people will say David not
everybody's a right-wing nut who goes to
Country Thunder okay the environment was
total right-wing nuttery in in like
Wisconsin this was like 15 years ago or
a long time ago I got roped into it by
people who like country music which I
don't like and uh it was an absolutely
fetid environment I mean it just just it
was a never again moment for me
big oof I'm sorry that you had to go
through that but hey I appreciate your
time David thank you so much there is
Dev from Syracuse going to have at it at
the live music events exciting exciting
stuff all right everybody that's where
we're getting to today we will take a
break I will take calls again that
unless they silence me
which they're trying to do by the way
who is they I don't know unless they
silence me we will take calls again uh
and we will also be right back after
this extremely short break
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
all right let's get to some of your
emails tweets Reddit posts smoke signals
and telegrams that have come in over the
last week or so you can always email
info davidpackman.com if you have
feedback for us and let's just get right
into it Melvin peachy
came
I don't know why I find that name funny
Melvin peachy says dude you need Jesus
how can you mock people and their faith
there is
t-h-e-r-e which is the wrong there
listen Jesus is not for me
um mocking people and their faith listen
this is not about mocking anything that
brings meaning to individuals
when we get to a point in society
where
beliefs that make no sense literally
are being imposed on civil government to
make law then I have a problem and yes I
may on some level mock those beliefs
there when it comes to private religious
views if you want to privately believe
in Noah's ark or
the Zeus or Thor or that you know a
Jewish Carpenter was the son of God born
to a virgin died then came back to life
and walked on water or whatever if you
want to privately believe that and not
impose it in any way
on civil governance and the way that
this country runs
okay go ahead and do it right I mean I
don't think it's accurate but go ahead
and do it
but the second that these right-wing
extremists introduce religious
justifications for telling women what
they are allowed to do with their bodies
in consultation with doctors as well as
I guess your your sacred texts now are
part of the consultation no and at that
point we're going to say this doesn't
make any sense and
um I don't believe that the left should
apologize for that believe whatever you
want to believe but don't not only don't
impose it on others don't use it as a
justification for civil government to
run in any particular way and that is
absolutely my position uh craigson says
about the mass shootings that we
continue to have in the United States
we've become numb to all this horror
that in itself is an indictment of
American culture and government policy I
could not agree more and this is
something I was recently I was recently
interviewed for a forthcoming written
profile which I'll share with you when
it's published and the topic of sort of
becoming desensitized to Insanity came
up
and I do everything I can
as someone who covers a lot of these
sorts of things on a daily basis I do
everything I can not to become
desensitized and you know during Trump
by the thousands time thousandth time
that he does something Bonkers like
using a Sharpie to draw on a hurricane
map or sending a reporter out of the
room like they're being sent to the
principal's office it's important to
fight normalization and Hyper
normalization of crazy things and I try
to remind myself of that but I admit
it can be tough
not to become desensitized to some
degree and the mass shootings I mean on
any day of the week you can go to gun
violence archive and look at the last 72
hours and you'll see individual gun
homicides and mass shootings every
single day and sometimes they don't even
really make the news it's an absolutely
terrifying reality
uh but it is where we are right now
and we have to find a way to do
something about it post it to the David
packman show subreddit by lochnar asking
opinion on Tulsi gabbard as Trump's VP
pick writing I think Tulsi might be an
option for Trump's VP pick as she would
fulfill the requirement of being a woman
as well as being a Russia Putin
apologist I think her not being white
could easily be spun into a positive for
racist right-wingers she's proven to
have no limit when it comes to debasing
herself for her own personal gain and
might pick up some low information
voters that still think she has some
credibility or Integrity the whole being
disillusioned with and leaving the
Democratic party could be turned into a
strength most of all I think she fits
Trump's image requirement that he wants
someone that looks like they're from
Central Casting I'm not trying to be
sexist myself writes lochnar but looking
at the situation from Trump's
perspective and how image obsessed he is
I don't think he'd go for someone like
Marjorie Taylor green for that reason
Nikki Haley I guess would be the most
obvious choice but I really think the
possibility exists for Tulsi to get
picked I'd probably put her before
Carrie Lake anyway with her just
basically being a sore loser anybody
else think this is possible yeah I mean
so I have two thoughts on this one I
don't believe Tulsi gabbard is going to
be Trump's VP pick but I agree with all
of the reasoning that lochnar uh lays
out for why Tulsi would actually fit
check a lot of the boxes she would be a
I'm reading uh the late David graber's
book BS jobs
and he talks about one category of BX BS
jobs is uh uh box Checkers so to speak
and Tulsi checks a lot of the boxes
she's not tough on Putin which works
well for Trump
um she has even though the right now
says they're against identity politics
she actually checks some identity boxes
that would allow those on the right to
say see we're not sexist we're not
racist it's a non-white woman I I mean I
guess I guess Tulsi gabbard's not white
it's not totally clear she's half
she's native Hawaiian I think or native
Native American I'm not actually sure uh
I don't do the identity thing so I'm
actually not sure what the deal is with
that she left the left which is super
popular you know Dave Rubin made a bunch
of money by leaving the left and and so
she has that I agree a hundred percent
for a bunch of reasons tool C would be a
great pick for Trump I don't think she
is who Trump is going to go for from the
YouTube channel Dynamic photography says
about gun violence there was an insane
amount of murders by stabbings and
vehicular impact over the weekend as
well are we going to discuss Banning
knifes
knives and vehicles as well news flash
we need to get to the bottom of our
mental health epidemic ASAP it's way
deeper than the tool that's used well
again we need to do both I am with
everybody on the right who says we need
to deal with the Mental Health crisis in
this country it would be nice if some of
the right Wingers saying that were
willing to actually put some money
towards funding dealing with the Mental
Health crisis many of them are not
willing to do that but I will go further
if we have mentally ill people some of
whom are prone to violence as the right
loves to say and they might have access
to knives vehicles and guns wouldn't we
want to restrict their access to guns
like do we want mentally ill people
predisposed to violence to have AR-15s
now you could say well they also
shouldn't have a knife they're going to
be able to kill way more people in a
short period of time with an AR-15 than
they are with a knife and then you know
often they go to this vehicle thing yeah
you can use Vehicles as a weapon but
Vehicles primarily have a completely
different purpose that is not to shoot
people oh but guns can be used for
target practice okay yeah but uh uh the
the the the primary function of the
history of a firearm was as a tool of
war and as a tool of killing not as a
tool of target practice primary function
of a vehicle is transportation and so
they they get all mixed up about it it's
kind of sad to see but we've got to keep
rebutting it because they keep saying it
Matt whites posted to our Facebook page
conservatives Time After Time come
around only when it happens to them they
are binary zero-sum immediate
gratification thinkers without the
capacity for empathy until it lands on
their lap I am afraid that the majority
of gun fetishizers and second amendment
contortionists will keep at it until the
accumulative corrosive effects on
society force their hands by then it may
be too late for civil America yeah I
mean we've seen many anti-gay
Republicans who all of a sudden their
nephew comes out or their daughter and
they change their View and unfortunately
that's going to take too long and it's
impractical when it comes to waiting
around for that to happen with gun
violence it just doesn't make sense and
it would be an insane amount of death
and destruction so I think I think the
comment is correct
personally facing gun violence might
change the views of some of these
Republicans some would not change their
minds
um but that we can't rely on that as a
way to fix the problem Frederick Simon
said on Facebook
I'm sorry to say it but I think a lot of
American people are willing to destroy
the country because they think Biden
will not make it through the entire next
presidential term if he wins and the
vice president would take over this is
the only reason I can think of because
if Trump wins we know where the country
would be headed a dictatorship
yeah listen I I'm not a hundred percent
sure I understand this one but I wanted
to include it because there there is
something really important here
would Trump
turn the U.S into a dictatorship if he
could
I think it's plausible that he would you
know when George W bush said this would
be a lot easier if it was a dictatorship
or whatever the case may be
I don't think Bush would turn the
country into a dictatorship given the
opportunity
I do believe that Trump actually would
but I don't believe he's going to really
get that opportunity and I know every
time I say this people write to me they
say David that's dangerous for you to
say that because you're minimizing that
no no no no I'm not minimizing the
threat I've been crystal clear about the
dangers presented by Trump
I do not believe that if Trump got four
more years he would turn the U.S into a
dictatorship even if that would be his
preference if you disagree with me let
me know Michael wrote in with a podcast
question says hey David uh Mike here
long time viewer first time emailer I
saw you on Lex Friedman's podcast which
is great I've been watching both of you
forever it made me wonder
when someone like you does a podcast
such as his is there payment involved
for that matter do any podcast guests
get compensated or do people view it as
an opportunity to get their name out
there thanks in advance okay
we have never paid
any of the thousand plus guests who we
have interviewed and I have never been
paid to be on any podcast either
that being said we have been asked for
payment a couple of times by guests I
won't tell you who they were they
actually weren't really big names it's
interesting the really big name seem to
understand you either do it or you don't
it's either worth doing or you don't you
either have time for it or you don't but
you don't you don't ask for money
mid high level guests
are the ones who have asked for money in
the past is this a paid appearance we
would do a pay uh and the answer is
always no and uh I believe this is
basically always the case now the
exception to this would be
if you get invited like right now for
example I'm uh in the middle of talking
with a it's not a podcast it's a show
that films in a different part of the
country
and
there they do offer compensation it's
not a podcast appearance it's sort of a
program that is being cast and there's a
there's a fee and they pay travel it's
sort of a different thing but as far as
podcasts like ours we have never paid
anyone I have never been paid and I have
never heard of anyone being paid okay
Richard Harris commented on YouTube
I find it incredible that so many
Americans could even contemplate voting
for Republican candidates after what
we've seen of Republican policies
particularly with regard to abortion and
other health care issues is stupidity or
ignorance mostly to blame well stupidity
and ignorance are kind of the same thing
I think the the better question is are
is is it stupidity is it selfishness or
is it a complete disregard for other
people that is to blame and I think the
answer is it's a combination of all of
those things and I've spoken about this
extensively before and unless we deal
with all three of those aspects I worry
we're not going to be able to get out of
this
sort of Doom stupidity cycle in which we
find ourselves today let me know what
you think stupidity uh uh
stupidity selfishness or or lack of uh
lack of concern for others which is more
to blame and what proportions send in
your emails info at davidpackman.com
remember that Monday Memorial day we'll
be doing a one-day membership special
it's going to be explosive like nothing
you've ever seen before if you've been
thinking maybe I'll sign up I don't know
it sounds kind of interesting Monday
Memorial Day is a great day to do it
all you need to do in order to be
notified about the Monday membership
special is to get on our newsletter at
davidpackman.com we'll see you on the
bonus show we'll see you back on Monday
foreign